starting with the top red box it looks
like it takes up the entire row and
contains a few elements inside of it so
this one's going to be row let's look at
the top blue box it contains a name and
title and it looks like it's taking up
about half of this whole row as a result
I'm gonna put column six however this
box could be larger than six why because
the text is right aligned if this box
were over here or if it expanded over
here it still looked the same
so your answer it could be larger than
column six but it's definitely no larger
than column ten for the bottom red box
it's taking up the entire row and it
contains some columns inside of it so
once again we have a row and then for
the bottom blue box here it's taking up
a third of this row a third of 12 is
four so this is going to be column or